i guess going back to tokyo is there any
other places or areas in tokyo's that
you like like i know it's like a massive
tourist trap but just go to golden gate
it's fun golem is good don't go into any
bars where a guy's telling you to go
into a bar yeah go into bars shinjuku
there's a lot of really cool places in
shinjuku but there's also a lot of
sketch places in shinjuku so yeah you
really have to be careful again if
someone tells you to go into a bar don't
go into that don't go into a bar that's
just a rule of thumb uh there's a bunch
of really cool bars not in
not so between and sanchome sanchome
there's a ton of really cool bars near
like behind the malls
like yeah there's a bunch of really uh
tightly knit areas that have a [ __ ] ton
of nice bars and nearly all of them i've
been into are pretty damn good okay yeah
yeah i think it's mostly when we think
of like sketch places in shinjuku it's
mostly like some parts of golden gai and
nichole
which is like the the gay bar district
um i've been to a few gay bars in
nicholmen and they're really really fun
but the problem is a lot of places they
won't let you in unless you're going in
with someone who they already know yeah
it's true yeah also a lot of them i
don't think are very foreigner friendly
either oh no there's quite a lot
actually oh really there's quite a lot
okay i've seen i've when i went filming
there and i've been there a few few
times there's a lot of bars that are
very very foreign
so if you want to experience gay bars in
japan and they are pretty dope at least
the ones i've been to yeah yeah i've got
an insurmount i mean i think gay bars
are just pretty dope in general check
out the one that i went to
it's an anime annie song gay bar and i
hate some gay bar so you know you know
that sounds fun as [ __ ] yeah oh yeah it
is all the details were just
gay bars are like some of the funnest
bars you can go to i say this as someone
who grew up in brighton uh where there
was a bunch of gay bars
everyone's just like so up for anything
and it's just like it's just it's it's
not up for anything it runs off right
now i can't stay up
also they're just a lot of fun
it's just a good vibe it's just a really
good bonding experience if you want to
like talk to japanese people especially
yeah yeah yeah uh daikonyama has a bunch
of cool balls
out of that area daikanyama dakonyama
does have a bunch of cool bars but they
do get a bit costly oh they're very
expensive but they're super super cool
like there's like breweries and daikon
yamaha oh the brewing diet was really
good that one's i don't think i've been
to daikon yes you have gone yeah i've
been we've been to the brewery
which brewery is it again is it the
spring valley yeah yeah oh that's like
that
oh i thought that was their business
that area has like like every single bar
i've been to in the area is sick okay
yeah so i i do agree with that i went to
the cigar bar and died on young oh okay
okay okay every bar in the area i've
been to is just awesome i just i just
completely blanked on the area neymar is
just like that's close to ebbis yeah you
can watch it from there
that's awesome as well
basically
is just south of shibuya yep um it's one
stop away and i'd say that it's like
i actually prefer episode over uh
shibuya even though shibuya is like the
the more famous place to go to because
to me shibuya is just way too crowded i
don't know yeah no i get that yeah like
there's also a lot of like really cool
places in shibuya if you know where
you're looking that's true uh you know a
lot of like shibuya's a lot like
yeah she is a lot like shinjuku where
like it is like heavily like infested
with a lot of tourist traps but yeah but
also shibuya is so massive that if you
go to like you know like uh [ __ ]
aoyama for example which is like the
area on the way towards harajuku like
that place has a lot of like really cool
like hidden stuff around as well which
and it's not really that far from
shibuya yeah i think like yeah one thing
i would definitely recommend if you're
going to like the big locations is to
like kind of
try to venture out of the center because
there you you do tend to find a lot of
really cool hidden stuff that isn't
overpriced to [ __ ] yeah uh and that
applies to like most places in tokyo
yeah exactly what do you guys think of
ikebukuro i really like ikebukuro right
well there's two sides two sides okay
there's two sides east side of ikebukuro
okay the west side is like very very
very sketchy yeah yeah the east is
sunshine city and everything around that
area is actually a city and uh and
ultimate road yeah yeah all that all
that here what i like about ikebukuro is
that you get a little bit of everything
you know it's it's it it is kind of like
you said that was so me me a little bit
of everything a little bit of everything
everybody you do kind of get a little
bit of everything yeah if you just want
to like go to an area and just you want
to get some anime you've got automobiles
yeah you've got some really really good
restaurants and really really good bars
you've got sun sunshine city
um yeah and then if you want uh a lot of
like really good like southeast asian
restaurants and like indian restaurants
you go to the west side of ikebukuro but
it's also very scary west side yeah
literally like i don't know what
happened okay yeah like the other side
is like literally just like
lots of sketchy places yeah to explain
you east side and west side um you're
not going to be able to easily wander
from one side to the other because it's
literally east side and west side of the
station so you literally have to go
through the station to get to either
side right
um and it's it's like
it's such a big dichotomy that i don't
like it's literally a [ __ ] line that
separates one like
the bougie side from like the really
really scat side and like i don't i
don't know how like one station can
separate like two areas that are just
are the complete opposite of each other
that's crazy on the train on one side
it's like oh you can eat oh all this and
the other side it's like women 500 yen
an hour yeah [ __ ] sex sex
there's a lot of people and like uh and
like uh host clubs and stuff like that
there's gonna be a lot of guys trying to
get you into a lot of girls bars yeah i
understand that you're saying you have a
[ __ ] yeah yeah each side's good
you've got a round one a really big
round one very big round one uh yeah and
sometimes shitty is a ton of malls yeah
yeah really good shopping really good
food uh lots of fun
i think so yeah they're round one it's
arcade plus uh bowling bowling plus uh
[ __ ] it's got everything yeah i'm pretty
sure you can live in that round one
alright yeah yeah right it's go it's got
fun what was the place that we filmed a
video about joey um oh the break room
the break room is that nikki bucaro yeah
that's an easter girl as well yeah
that's an easy kabuki
that's actually like i want to go back
there i want to go back
yeah yeah so if you've seen the joey uh
joey's video with me and him during the
break room uh where you get to just
break a bunch of [ __ ] they'd have more
than that there as well they have like
axe throwing they have axe throwing
there and uh what is it now
yeah where you can like spray paint or
yeah you know just uh that's a really
cool place
and you can drink there as well it's got
a lot of like games there as well you
should also go to uh baggers i love
vegas
into google whenever you're here and i
guarantee there'll be one within a
walking distance of you if you're in
tokyo yeah and you can play uh there's a
variety of things the three staples they
have are ping pong uh pool and uh i
actually recently filmed a video at the
ikabukuro vegas which i hope it's out by
the time this episode sounds like the
grand one yeah it's the big one on
sunshine road like mexico cinemas what
else can you do in that one because
you have golf yeah you can do golf ping
pong pull darts and i think that one in
ikebukuro has the largest selection of
manga oh okay and they also have like uh
they also have like a theater rooms as
well oh and you can just like if you
like rent out movies uh from outside of
baggage you can't do it inside the bags
but if you go to like a rental place you
can bring in like games and like rental
games and like rental movies you can
just like have a room to yourself let's
play games and move also the darts in
japan is not it's no basic darts this is
like
cyberpunk darts
like it's like the board is like a score
there's animations and [ __ ] this thing
is so fun you gotta go yeah
yeah also you know ordering drinks is
kind of can be kind of stressful if you
don't know any japanese uh basically
there'll be a phone next to your table a
lot of these places
now they just have tablets do they
backus does yeah i went in the bags the
other day you had to call oh really some
of them you have to call it some of them
have to call it you call up you just say
the name of the drink you want and then
say
ichi or knee yeah just just say three
phases uh
the third the third the third phase uh
phrase sorry is uh namabee
which is just like you just say numbers
or just number yeah which just means
like the beer on tap or the draft beer
or the craft beer default beer um that's
just basically the only drink i ordered
when i came to japan for the first time
that's good japanese very drinkable i'd
say i wouldn't i wouldn't say it's the
nicest but just very easy it goes down
it's the thing about japanese beers it's
just very it's
it's it's kind of like
refreshing you know what i mean because
i was going to say it's like water but
it's that's that's not doing it justice
you know it's just very you know it's
not it's not american beer yeah it's
it's not what it's like
necessarily it's not it's no middle line
it's just refreshing you know because
you could it's very light without being
without feeling like it's a very cheap
beer it's how do i yeah it's like it
goes down really light but you still get
the full taste of the beef yeah yeah
exactly i don't know how they do it's
like some japanese wheeze jury happening